Donc si j'ai bien compris,
le mec si on le fait pas rire,
il meurt, c'est ça?
Oui là, t'es relou!
D'accord. Mais alors
pourquoi ils font appel à nous
alors qu'ils ont des infiltrés?
-Mais t'es chiant avec tes questions.
Les mecs ils sont bloqués dans les embouteillages
donc nous on est juste là
pour préparer le terrain quoi.
D'accord. Donc on se fait un peu exploité quoi
genre ils aiment pas prendre le métro
du coup nous
on leur fait gagner du temps.
Bordel, fallait pas se présenter à ce boulot
si tu voulais pas le faire
Mais oh!
Tu sais combien ça paye le stand up?
"Ok, les intérimaires
vous êtes en place? "
Oui, oui, on est tous là Monsieur.
-"Ok la cible c'est Nicolas Douvil,"
"patient numéro 12,
il vient de se faire licencier. "
"On est en chemin,
on arrive pour lui faire la remontée,"
"en attendant il faut surtout pas qu'il sombre.
Donc faites le rire."
Donc euh ...
On va faire simple.
Jules, tu passes devant lui
et tu te vautres la gueule.
Ca marche.
-Ensuite
il nous faut un truc chelou,
un petit peu inattendu ...
Ouais, genre ...
(Rire Bizarre)
C'est bien ça?
Non. En fait moi
je vais passer avec Morpheus
et je vais faire style
je contrôle plus le chien.
Sam, tu t'assois à côté de lui
et tu lâches une grosse caisse !
- Bon? ... D'accord.
Si après tout ça le Nicolas il rigole pas,
on sort...
le sac d'urgence.
-On le tue?
Non, on le tue pas.
On fait des trucs, on improvise,
on fait des trucs drôles.
Y'a de l'hélium,
c'est bien ça, on le fait poiler,
on le fait poiler.
Et du coup, comment on sait
s'il va sombrer le Nicolas?
Ses yeux deviennent chelou,
et il commence à trembler.
D'accord ok.
Tu t'es juste pas du tout
renseigner sur ce boulot en fait.
Non. Non.
Je fais du stand up.
Je ne suis pas habitué
à péter sur des mutants dépressifs.
Je marche vers la cible,
je vais bientôt me casser la gueule.
La prochaine fois c'est pas moi qui me fait mal,
y'en a marre.
Ouais on verra. Mais tu te vautres la gueule
mais genre bien quoi.
Ah putain sa mère.
Ca va monsieur?
-Ouais ça va, t'inquiètes pas Nico...
Nique, nique euh ...
Nique ta mère enculer!
Putain mais t'es trop con!
Désolé j'ai paniqué.
-Sam, tu te tiens prêt, j'y vais.
Oui, je suis là, je suis prêt.
Oh la la, ah non
mais il est ingérable ce chien!
Mais cours putain Morpheus, merde!
Fais un truc débile Virgile,
il rigole pas du tout là.
Ok, nul, ça marche pas en fait.
J'ai l'impression qu'il se met à trembler.
Sam, il faut que tu y ailles.
Oui, j'y vais, je suis prêt.
Allez Sam, lâche une caisse putain.
Il tremble de plus en plus.
Fais pas le con Sam,
lâche un prout!
Allez Sam, mais pètes putain.
-J'y arrive pas!
Bon ok, je ramène le sac d'urgence.
-Non, c'est bon, je peux le faire.
Tirez sur mon doigt !
Quoi?
Tirez sur mon doigt, c'est marrant.
On a besoin d'une équipe de nettoyage ici,
on a merdé.
Bon écoute, je te ramène chez toi.
Tu te reposes,
tu prends une douche
et on reparle de tout ça demain quoi.
Putain on va se faire défoncer ...
Et comment on sait qu'il est pas un ...?
Non, c'est pas quelque chose qu'on devient,
c'est quelque chose qu'on est.
Moi je pense qu'on peut l'attraper, moi.
Ta mère
Allez!
Putain de merde!
T'es sûr qu'on a bien fait
de le laisser tout seul?
Non mais lui il est pas dépressif.
Il fait du stand up,
il est forcément dépressif.
Ça va aller mec,
ça va aller !
Il m'arrive quoi?
-Fais le marrer, fais quelque chose toi!
Mais je sais pasmoi,
j'en sais rien!
Mais putain ça marche jamais ça en fait.
Attends, j'ai lu un tweet marrant tout à l'heure.
-Un tweet?
Tu veux le faire marrer avec un tweet?
Mais j'en sais rien moi!
Putain je vais chercher le sac d'urgence !
Putain, pourquoi tu l'as pas pris avant?
-Ta gueule!
T'inquiètes pas, ça va aller.
Un truc marrant?
Mon deuxième prénom c'est Valéry,
c'est marrant ça?
Quand je me torche le cul,
je me le torche par l'avant.
Quoi?
Je sais pas,
j'ai toujours fait comme ça,
c'est bizarre.
C'est bizarre de faire ça quand même hein.
Oui c'est bizarre...
ça va?
Oh putain,
tu m'as fait peur.
Ça va aller mec, ça va aller.
Ah bah ça va, il est calmé.